depuis le 17 mars dernier il faut
montrer patte blanche pour traverser la
frontière franco espagnole
seuls quelques catégories de personnes
dont les travailleurs transfrontaliers
et le personnel diplomatique ont
l'autorisation de passer d'un pays à
l'autre sur un même pont des policiers
des deux états sont mobilisés pour
contrôler les justificatifs
une nouvelle disposition qui entraîne
inévitablement une baisse d'activité
pour les petits commerces
ça c'est frustrant quand même de voir la
frontière fermée on a l'impression
d'être
[Musique]
enfermé tout simplement l'habitude de
passer tous les jours elle a du coup
depuis une semaine derni passe plus de
temps à ben moi je travaille dans un bar
juste cela et voilà je travaille j'ai
arrêté de travailler je suis professeur
de yoga aussi j'ai arrêté de donner les
cours de yoga
voilà donc c'est certain
autant d'argent en moins qui rentrent
tous les mois quoi des rues désertes qui
tranche avec l'habituel effervescence
des villes transfrontalière pourtant une
chose ne change pas le nombre de camions
qui traversent la frontière
un va et vient incessant qui entraîne
l'incompréhension des habitants
je trouve qu'il ya un abus on nous parle
de fermer les frontières on nous parle
de beaucoup de choses et sur cette
autoroute qui a des centaines et des
centaines de camions qui passent chaque
jour avec deux des voitures en ferraille
des voitures sont les remorques alors
qu'on fasse passer les produits de
primaire c'est-à-dire la nourriture et
tout ça il n'y a pas de problème et
enfin de tout le cas de la bu le corps
quand on avait russe et transportant
camions de toute l'europe qui passent
par cette frontière
je trouve ça débile sa santé frontières
soient fermés ce que ça ne sera pas le
virus de passé et personne n'a pris les
confinements en remontant donc donc ça
change rien que ça soit fermé ou ouvert
franchement ça change rien mais
tandis qu'ils ont plus de cas chez eux
que chez nous voilà on peut comprendre
qu'ils aient peur mais on aura la même
chose en france à l'instar de leurs
voisins français certains espagnols de
france en colère pointe du doigt le
gouvernement de pedro sanchez
ils l'accusent de ne pas avoir réagi à
temps il ya beaucoup d beaucoup des
jeunes contaminés
on n'a pas été vraiment dire la
situation je trouve qu'elle n'a pas été
géré comme il fallait et maintenant nous
sommes en train de détruire les
conséquences de la mauvaise organisation
c'est très grave et moi je pense que les
gens ils commencent à en prendre
conscience et maintenant des de la
gravité de la situation
s'il arrive quelque chose à mes parents
je peux pas trouver ça ne peut pas
passer à côté parce qu'il dit sur
resident français et il n'y a pas le
droit de traverser l'autre côté je suis
en colère parce que nous on pense qu'on
va vite en europe l arpa il doit faire
tous les pays la même chose le bilan
humain de l'espagne a dépassé celui de
la chine
le gouvernement espagnol durcit encore
les règles de confinement l'état d'
alerte a été prolongée jusqu'au 14 avril
prochain